le premier ministre jean castex était
hier à trappes pour promouvoir
l'apprentissage avec la ministre du
travail
elisabeth bornes et la ministre déléguée
auprès de la ministre de la cohésion du
territoire nadia et il s'est rendu dans
l'entreprise connaît l'un des leaders
dans le secteur des ascenseurs qui
dispose d'un centre de formation
continue
c'est pas tous les jours qu'on a la
visite d'un premier ministre un attrape
visitant une très belle entreprise de
notre territoire connaît surtout pour
promouvoir l'apprentissage c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup de dispositifs qui
existent à destination de nos jeunes
dont les entreprises sont souvent pas
toujours parfaitement au courant et
c'est vrai qu'il faut que les
entreprises les mobilisent parce que sa
lutte contre le chômage d'une population
les jeunes qui sont durement impactée
par la crise sanitaire pour répondre aux
difficultés des jeunes le gouvernement a
lancé l'été dernier
en plus de la réforme de l'apprentissage
de 2018 le plan un jeune une solution ce
plan se traduit par des aides à
l'embauché des aides financières ou
encore des formations
cette visite à trappes a aussi été
l'occasion pour les ministres de
rencontrer des jeunes en apprentissage
ils ont beaucoup parlé de leur
expérience d'apprentissage et ils sont
évidemment ravis de cette possibilité
d'être formés et cali su trouver un
emploi n'est cassé tout le l'enjeu de
l'apprentissage en 2019 la france
comptait 485 milles 800 apprentis soit
59 de plus qu'en 2018 ces nouveaux
dispositifs mis en place par le
gouvernement doivent donc permettre
d'augmenter encore le nombre d'apprentis
en france